so before we get started into this
week's topic let's talk about the news
so really to two pieces of news for
Android developers firstly google play
services has launched we're really
excited about this it now provides the
oaths identity management or both if you
provide you all tokens so that you can
use a single nice API that abstracts the
whole our side of things for you across
all of our Google services and we also
have the Google+ SDK as part of that so
Google Play services is quite
interesting because what it is is that
the component that's actually going to
be there on users devices so the as part
of the Google Play Store the google play
services component will be installed and
now as developers you can just go ahead
and start using that new API so this is
just the start of something much bigger
Google Play services will grow and I was
two and Google+ are finally here so
that's that's really good and the other
thing I'm really excited about this is
that we have a new build system coming
for the Android developer tools so we
would our team xavier Durocher has put
up a document or the sort of describes
some of the changes that are coming up
they're not I available in a stable
release yet but you can certainly go and
go and have a look at that document and
see what kind of changes are coming so
yeah this is this is good stuff more
more tools for developers is always a
good thing all right so it's tablet week
so our focus today is to really use the
word tablet as much as possible no
that's not true and we we we want to
basically empower developers to build
apps that that work well on phones and
tablets so we're actually going to have
a series of presentations on a do plus
over the coming weeks today's the first
one and it's really about the
fundamental building blocks of these
apps and
and it's really fragments though those
are the components that you use so today
is very much a primer on fragments and
so we're going to cover a few things but
before we do let's talk about some
fundamental goals that developers would
like to have or we always want to have
when we build phone and tablet apps
firstly we want to have a single app for
mob right we don't want to have to
manage a different set of code for a
phone version for a tablet version or
even for a Google TV version as much as
possible we want to maximize our code
reuse and in doing so you kind of want
to have your code you know be quite
decoupled so that you can you can build
these reusable components and have them
not totally depend on the other
components being the decoupling is
obviously a really good thing in general
software design and finally you want to
build these apps such that they're
backward compatible Android 3.0 is where
or honeycomb is where we first
introduced tablets and prior to that you
know we had Gingerbread and Froyo now
gingerbread is still a very popular
version of the platform so when we talk
about these fragments and utilizing them
we want to do it in a way that still
allows our apps to run on these older
versions so we're going to touch touch
on that too how do we make sure that
they're backward compatible whilst
keeping all these these goals in mind so
what are fragments well fragments
they're really reusable components so
it's about grouping bits of you you I or
other common functionality so that you
can then use it in these standalone
classes so when we think about taking a
nap and making it available on tablets
what we want to do is really promote the
idea of that the fact that you should
really rethink your you I don't just
take your phone layout and stretch it
because that's not really a good
experience and in the majority of cases
stretching out you know a typical list
or something like that on a phone and
just stretching it out onto a tablet
doesn't doesn't really result in a good
user experience and uses never sentence
him to appreciate that so in as you can
see from this diagram here where you
might have had two activities one and
two
what you would do is actually take the
contents of those activities and put
them into fragments then on the phone
you'll be showing one fragment at a time
whereas on the tablet you can show both
fragments at a time within a single
activity so the activity is still that
out of window and you can see it based
on the blue border you still have
activities when you're running on phones
and tablets and we're not moving away
from activities but we're taking out all
of that that code that we had within the
activity around the user interface and
just regrouping it into fragments so
what are fragments well fragments are
basically reusable UI components by
grouping our our contents that we would
have had in an activity it means that we
can take be flexible with these
fragments so you know being a fragment
isn't just like an include in your
layout there's actually more to it than
that it actually participates as part of
the life cycle so fragments actually
have a life cycle and they're attached
to an activity and that's really
important because the activity will
initialize them at key points it'll
populate them and there are some
specific overloads that you should be
aware of fragments can also maintain
their own back stack so in you know you
know typical phone app you might go from
one activity to the next to the next but
if you now start reusing these the
contents of those activities and
fragments you might use a single
activity and just transition from one
fragment to the next now when the user
hits the back button you don't want it
to go from one activity to the previous
one you want to make sure you you
navigate backwards through the fragment
stack before you go to the previous
activity so fragments allow this the
other thing to keep in mind is that
fragments don't have to be UI components
they can just be background workers that
you instantiate and that participate is
part of the life cycle so we have an API
called fine fragment by tag so typically
what you'd have is you'd have a fragment
that you put in a layout and you do a
you know a fine view by ID and grab the
layout and so on and so forth but you
can actually instead
cope fragments using the fragment
manager you can basically name them or
tag them so this fine fragment by tag is
a way to basically get a hold of that
fragment at runtime without having to
rely on things like the view hierarchy
so let's talk a little bit about
fragments and activities in general so
fragments the user interface part is
optional typically you know in most
circumstances you would use them with a
user interface that they're really for
grouping you would use them for grouping
you I but you don't have to whereas with
an activity it always has a user
interface right it's always the the part
that the user sees both of them tend to
have lifecycle methods and in fact the
fragment tends to have a few more
lifecycle methods than the activity and
the typical sort of a UI style star
fragment fragments can't be standalone
they are attached to activities right
and we actually have an override called
on a catch and I'm detach now the other
thing you should be aware of is the the
use of intense so typically we use
intense to invoke certain pieces of
functionality in your activity that
still holds true except with fragments
intense don't go don't fire up fragments
directly you have to go through an
activity and we're going to clarify this
later so what we're doing here is first
describing what what fragments are going
to look at now the advantages of using
fragments and then eventually we will
talk about backward oh sorry before
it'll web back support we're going to
talk about communication as well between
fragments so let's look at a typical
layer on a phone you know this is the
People app that we've had this since our
ice cream sandwich and you'll see on the
on the left hand side you've got to lift
you with this list view you you have
your list of contacts there and as
there's some tabs across the top you can
swipe across them and so on you know
it's a fairly standard list view touch
screen but some actions along the bottom
now if we were to click Matthias there
it will take us from the ListView for
that contact and go into the detail view
now
you a traditional phone app may have
implemented these as activity one for
the list view and activity two for the
detailed view but if we then reorganize
our code such that this list view part
of it becomes a fragment and the
detailed view also becomes a fragment
then what happens is on the phone we
still we can still present the same
interface but when we go to something
like the tablet we can show these
multiple fragments at the same time
we're maximizing our code reuse we're
not having to define layouts multiple
times and even code multiple times or
having really complex inheritance
hierarchies with fragments we can
basically do show multiple pieces of you
I at the same time there is some extra
code that you need to do to distinguish
between a phone layout and a tablet
layer I'm going to look at that next but
the difference is really phenomenal in
terms of the the overhead for you and
your developers so when it comes to
defining layouts you might be saying
well at what point how can I say that
this this layout is going to be for a
phone or a tablet well in our in Eclipse
when you define your your resource or
your layout directories you can
basically just but you can say it's a
layout directory which will you know be
the default layout that gets used or you
can have these extra qualifiers so one
of the qualifiers is something that we
call smallest width and then you can
specify number and a DP now smallest
width basically says that regardless of
whether I'm holding it in portrait or
landscape view what is the smallest
dimension on this device now what we've
done is that we've got some metrics in
there that tell you that this is the
range of values that will result in a
tablet UI or phone UI so if you specify
smallest width 600 anything that has 600
DPS or greater is considered a tablet
okay we've in fact added an extra layer
of differentiation there if you specify
600 DP it'll get picked up by 7-inch
tablets if you specify 720 DP it'll
actually get picked up by 10 inch
tablets so you may want to have a diff
lay out between your 7-inch tablets and
your 10-inch tablets and this metric
here is how you do that and then you'd
still have a normal layout folder and
that normal layout folder is what will
get picked up for phones the 600 DP for
7-inch tablets and the 720 DP four
10-inch tablets you don't have to have
all three there's nothing that sort of
forcing you to do so but our
recommendation is at least have to have
the default layout folder and then have
the 600 DP for your tablet UI now prior
to Android 3.2 so really only android
3.0 and 3.1 the only way that you could
have a tablet layout was to specify a
red large or as sorry that should say
layout large and layout extra-large
directory now in fact I'm going to just
fix that live right now because I can
and we're done so it's a layout large
and layout extra-large directory because
prior to Android 3.2 we didn't have that
smallest with qualifier so a larger and
extra large layout would actually get
picked up by those devices we no longer
recommend that you use large and
extra-large qualifies because it becomes
a little bit of a gray area you know
what defines a large large screen is it
a is it a 7-inch tablet like the Nexus 7
or you know it's something like a galaxy
note considered a large screen so rather
than having these these generic buckets
we now use the smallest with qualifying
and you should too so at runtime how
would you tell between whether you're
running in a phone layout or tablet
layer well it's easy right because in in
your activity you're going to have a
layout that you load and on the phone
you would typically only be shown one
fragment at the time right on a tablet
you might show more than one fragment at
a time so what you can do is use a fine
view by ID API and see if you can find
both fragments for example and if you
you're only able to find one fragment
then you know that you're running on a
phone right if you're able to find both
fragments then you know that you're
running in a tablet and so that's that X
sort of glue code that i was talking to
but it really belongs in your activity
because remember fragments themselves
should be standalone reusable components
that are fairly decoupled from
everything else it's the activity that
kind of binds the multiple fragments or
really your layout that binds the
multiple fragments together so you can
just use a trick like that with using
fine view by ID and doing a null check
and uh that should sort you out so we
talked about intense before typically
what happens is when an intent gets
fired off your activity gets invoked and
said hey yes told he isn't in 10 but you
can't go from an intent directly to a
fragment it still comes through to an
activity so you might be wondering well
how do I manage that to how do i get an
intent to end up invoking a fragment and
the answer is it has to go through an
activity but let me just show you some
code that demonstrates how that that
propagation may work ah so let me just
highlight the relevant section so here
what's happened is where we're in the it
could happen in oncreate or it could
happen on on you and 10 and what you do
is basically do a get in can call so
this code is actually in your activity
itself right and so we just do a get
intent we get the action and we're just
comparing whether that the the intent
action matches whatever action it is
that we're interested in so once we do
that in our activity we can then go okay
I know that it is this action so now I'm
going to go and get hold of my note list
fragment so in this activity there might
there's probably a list fragment and a
detail fragment so a list of notes and
then the detail fragment was probably
the note itself so what we did is we got
the intent now we managed to pull the
relevant fragment out and then finally
we are able to pass in some extra
information or sorry from the intent we
can get some extra information out as to
which list item we want to select or or
so on and so forth but this is an
example of where in the activity we
received the intent and then we followed
that through and passed it through the
relevant fragment so we are kind of
starting to spread
out our code a little bit between
different classes but that's not
necessarily a bad thing either okay so
we talked about intent communication but
what about when you've got two fragments
and you want to communicate with one
another you could do all sorts of sort
of trickery where you've got fragments
talking to fragments but it's generally
not a good thing because then you start
to really closely couple them together
then one fragment needs to know whether
the other fragment exists and has been
loaded and so on and so forth and then
pass information back and forth instead
what we recommend if you still use the
activity as kind of a proxy so what you
would do to achieve fragment of fragment
communication is go via the activity so
here you'll see that what we recommend
is that you define an interface in frame
of one we're calling it in FSA for now
and fragment two would having a face be
defined the activity would implement
those methods okay and then when those
methods are being called on those
interfaces it would then pass it on to
the relevant fragment and it may in fact
like on a phone it may actually need to
instantiate the second fragment because
on a phone that both fragments may not
have been instantiated because that you
know single fragment lay out what loaded
so really the activity is that thing
that's binding it all together right so
what would happen is that once all of
these the interfaces are defined in the
activity is implementing them your
fragments are invoking the activity and
then the activity even turn is calling
the fragment so let's look at some code
that demonstrates that so on attaches a
is within a fragment that that's an
overload that says sorry an override
that says that your fragment has been
attached to a particular activity and
that's when it gets cold so when we get
attached when our fragment gets attached
to an activity we're just storing that
activity is a callback object within the
frame when itself okay and you'll notice
that the the type of that callback
object is this note list event call back
that's our interface which which is at
the bottom of this this page but we'll
talk about that in a minute but anyway
we store it as an interface and then on
our friend in this on list item
click method when we need to go and do
something about the fact that the user
has selected something we then can do it
one of two ways we can just call gate
activity and then go to call the the do
something method or we can use the
interface itself which we stored as a
callback object in the honor catch
method now my personal preference is to
use the callback I think it's cleaner
we've defined clear interfaces so again
we're we're kind of decoupling our code
quite nicely so you'd call call back
down on list no clicked and passing the
ID now remember we talked about at the
start in this honor catch method we
stored this callback and we said it had
to implement an interface well that's
what this bit of the bottom is it's the
interface that this fragment is defining
to say hey which ever met whichever
object I need to sort of inform that
that a particular action is taken that
object will obviously implement this
this method itself and I'll pass in a
note idea or whatever it may be so
communication between fragments don't do
it directly from fragment of fragment
have a proxy layer and that's typically
the activity because the activity is is
the thing that fragments are attached to
so we talked about some nice things here
but I also mentioned that fragments came
into android 3.0 the good news is that
we actually introduced fragments in the
support library so the support library
is a reusable library you may have heard
me mention it before it's really simple
to include in your project and within
eclipse you just right-click the project
go to Android tools and say add support
library it will go and download the
latest version include the the jar on
your project and set up the the build
path for you as well and the namespace
is then available so we basically put
backward compatible fragments in the
support library now my recommendation to
developers is use these support
fragrance from the start anytime you're
building a new app start with fragments
think about tablets and phones as
effectively being first class citizens
try not to start with a phone app and
then you know migrate to a tablet out
later you may choose to do the tablet
side of things later on but at least set
up the infrastructure and start using
fragments from the very beginning
because it's a lot easier than to manage
a tablet version of your app whereas if
you don't use fragments and then later
on you have to go and reorganize all of
your activities and so on in fragments
the overhead is a lot more later on
because you've got a big chunk of code
that you need to refactor so the support
library has fragment and one other
really important piece of advice is
don't mix and match support fragments
with the native fragments that you'll
find on android 3.0 and upwards they're
different implementations they're
different classes so you kind of mix and
match a support fragment and a native
fragment but we are able to achieve
backward compatibility and that is how
all of our internal apps work as well
you'll notice things like I showed you
the People app which is obviously an ice
cream sandwich at but even things like
gmail gmail uses multiple multiple
fragments anyways so that's backward
compatibility and that's and a bit of a
primer on fragments that's so let's move
on to Q&A does that anyone on the on the
thread here have any questions on
today's topic or even otherwise I'm just
going to go look at the thread doesn't
look like there's been any question
posted there's a question so there you
going to share this presentation after
this session and the answer is yes it's
available on YouTube because the
recording goes up and it's a it'll be
there so you can you can go in the view
it at any point in time all right so
there's no questions there my colleague
on hero dies is joining us from
Hyderabad on your do we should we move
to Google moderator yes
thanks for the function angle so let's
let's take up the questions in moderator
the first one and I'm going to read it
cloud my music nail appt audio streaming
should work while I'm driving in a car
with 3g guard what are the API features
should I consider as a developer the
player apps works excellent with Wi-Fi
and some devices with feet right how
could you wanna take that up yeah sure
look in general there's no very there's
no specific API that you know you want
to use to differentiate your behavior
your apps behavior but there's some
straight so with 3g it's it's not a good
idea to continually have the radio on as
much as possible you want to prefetch
and and chunk it up if you can do that
when you're on Wi-Fi that's even better
but streaming and you know just having a
constant or asking for chunks or buffers
of data periodically is probably not the
best way to do it because it will have a
significant drain on the user's device
so yeah prefetching is one really good
thing rate her minor our colleague
presented at Google i/o this year and it
was the the talk was making good apps
great so check it out there's some great
advice in there on how to achieve some
of this but what you can do to work out
whether you are connected to Wi-Fi or 3G
is use the connectivity manager and then
you know change your behavior
accordingly um and also keep in mind
that if you are pulling down lots of
data and you know prefetch can be at one
of those sensitive things just make sure
the users okay with you doing that so if
the user it's a music player you said
right so if the user has two gigabytes
of music you probably don't want to
download that on their 3g connection
because you you're going to blow through
their data limit Wi-Fi is typically
better most people are okay with Wi-Fi
but again you need to consider their
data limits on Wi-Fi
Junior behavior accordingly also the
last thing is if you are sort of
prefetching and casing just keep in mind
how large your patience becoming you
might want to manage that you might want
to have some maximum threshold set on
the app itself so that you're not using
up all of the users capacity storage
capacity is there anything else you want
to add on your uh yep so he also asked
what API features should I consider as a
developer so building a music app the
two things i would recommend a plate
approach from the rich notification bar
it's just very handy for you this and
also lock screen widget if you have your
controls there because if somebody is
driving a car with the 3g card or
playing with Wi-Fi a you don't wanna him
to get on lock the phone and go ahead
and stop your music or do whatever so
the not screen widget and notification
bar patron certificate those are a
couple of API teaches you should look at
actually also the bluetooth music
controls yeah so we've got api's around
that so you can respond to buttons on
people bluetooth headset so unless i
play pause next so on alright thanks
okay so the next question is I'm trying
to make an app using connectivity API is
a communication between devices or is it
between applications what is the primary
connectivity devices or applications
what is the security there is a app
level or device fairly so I easily gave
a talk on connectivity API during
deference bangalore and i think the
question is coming from there as a
follow-up question so i'll try to answer
this so when we say connectivity the api
what we getting minions are api is right
finally city is like Wi-Fi and filter
and beam which you could use to
communicate between devices and also
with the cloud like Wi-Fi so couldn't is
it is a communication devices or it's
between applications so it's a really
communication between devices but we've
got some app level features that you can
use a for example with Wi-Fi direct
about using service discovery which is
an app level feature so if your app is
using Wi-Fi direct to connect with
another device you can use these are
available as framework components just
like the telephony manager and network
connectivity manager you have a Wi-Fi
peer-to-peer manager available in your
app when you extend the front of any
type of activity and you could use this
15 manager to discover other services
around you in the bar fight it so the
the connection is really between the
devices because Wi-Fi but then your
application has some extra features from
the framework available on top of which
you can write your application and the
same goes for security layer so there if
you using Wi-Fi direct for example you
have you have options to use something
from the framework which is like the key
based authentication or the base use the
pin based authentication using that the
of the general wireless security options
are available to you but on top of that
you could build something on your app as
well you could you could also pinko
there you could ask for usually
thousands or and that same goes for do
talk another connectivity yet so it's
really that we provide core
infrastructure of security and data
transfer using our api's of the fridge
at the device level at the framework
level and on top of that you give you
some more flexibility in terms from what
I can tell yeah so I could do you like
to add something now actually I was
quite comprehensive all right ok the
next question is and this is from
Melbourne Jeff I'm trying to use a
search view in an action bar in my team
in space some team not followed like the
dark action bar I have an issue in which
i cannot find where to set the color of
the edict x and research view can i use
a custom layout for the search p uh so
i'm not really sure on the answer for
this one i think the answer is that my
guess is that the
attributes available on research we are
not customizable incense they are not
spy double attribute so you if you
really need to change the color you
probably would want to grab the view
from the layout during runtime
programmatically balance on uncreate we
would want an interview with the search
search view ID inside your on faith and
try to grab a reference to leave you and
then modify the properties on it by
exploring the layout file of research
trip so it's not simple what i can do is
I'll send a note to our UI team and see
if they have any suggestions on what can
be done here but I'm my i doubt if you
can customize the interns with
incredible attitudes all right let's go
to the next question I hi I am a
beginner in Android development and I
need some help about getting form and
URI information from an uri and
displayed in that would be why so i
think this is a very basic question and
pretty broad question so in terms of
displaying it in the good vibe we have
plenty of UI components available and
some training classes available
developer.android.com there are also a
lot of patterns and practices which you
give the runabout from
developer.android.com / design we have
some design guidelines on how to build a
good UI and some of the sessions we've
covered in our area plus show so you
could also visit our playlist and from
youtube and go back and catch up on some
of the sessions so bringing a good you
is kind of a broad question and there's
a lot of there's a lot of resources
available on our developer site to some
of these type shows when comes to
grabbing information from a URL so you I
show you what you would need is Internet
formation on your application first
thing and then you could use a standard
Java URL connection hey guys which would
allow you to connect
host and you could set the appropriate
headers or authentication scheme using
you are in connection and then download
the data by as an HTTP response so
that's that's for doing it and one thing
to note here is that anybody gingerbread
we recommend that default HTTP fine
unfortunately Brad we recommend using
URL connection because the there were
some issues with your introduction like
the fortune your pet so if you are
building an app that's meant to be
compatible across the entire range of
devices and it should be you should
consider that fact so if you look at the
during run time you could people look at
the build of the OS and then choose to
use a different line to get the data so
that's key for HTTP client feedback I'm
put any more resources you would like to
point to or no I just a colleague David
Chandler had written a nice little
library to fetch information from from
the net basically passing the URL and
you know it just sort of abstracted a
lot of the detail for you so good yeah
yeah look up David Chandler on Google+
and he's got a really nice library that
you could use I can I can take this one
could you please describe the best
strategy for working with fragments and
loaders in a map activity any plans of
supporting fragments in a map activity
um so the honest you're honest truth is
it's it's pretty difficult right you can
use the map activity is is something
that we sort of released fairly early on
and it obviously provides the map
component part of it but it's not a
traditional activity you can't what what
you need is a fragment activity from the
support library if you want to use
fragments so in some ways map activity
and fragment activities are kind of
divergent from one another so it's I've
seen developers do it with all sorts of
tricks and hacks but I also know that
there's been
some complications in having to do it
that way we would love to be able to
just use maps in a fragment but there
you know we haven't we as in Google have
it published anything yet it's actually
a fairly common request that we get and
so we are we're definitely looking into
it but we don't have anything to
announce from a map fragment point of
view so I yeah I think that was the last
question oh there's any other question
on the on the on a thread which it
doesn't seem to be and it does anyone
live have any other questions before we
or should we wrap up is the other
question so I think Valis Abu from
Bangalore who asked the connectivity API
question about the hand of here so if
you have any other follow-up questions
for us was like all right well it
doesn't look like it maybe he's shy but
or maybe he just doesn't have any
follow-up questions so on that note I
guess we'll head off thank you for
joining us again and we'll be back same
time next week thanks for joining thank
you